hallo wir sind heute in der
hellbergschule news mende dänemark wir
zeigen euch heute den genitiv der
genitiv ist ein fall der im deutschen
sehr selten benutzt wird
er antwortet auf die frage wessen
wissenschaften ist dass das ist der
schatten des baumes
das ist tue das ist das haus steht im
schatten des hauses das ist der
fitnessraum
das sind die fitnessgeräte
wir benutzen die geräte des fitnessraums
das ist der rucksack passt ist janus
janus schlägt in die seite des rucksacks
das ist eine hantel das gewicht der
hantel ist zehn kilo das ist der ball
die wucht des balles haut camilla um
wir sind in einer schule
das ist der aufenthaltsraum das ist der
aufenthaltsraum der schule
das ist der tiger tisch der schule
familie und mir spielen kicker der
punktestand des spiels ist eins zu null
das ist der torwart des blauen teams das
war das erste tor des roten teams das
ist eine magnettafel sauer und mir
besprechen die taktik des spiels das ist
die tischtennisplatte
das ist die tischtennisplatte der schule
das ist das netz das ist das netz der
tischtennisplatte wetten flasche ist das
meine das ist kameras klasse messen
schlüsselbund ist das meiner das ist der
schlüssel und der lehrerin
das ist die kantine
das ist das geschirr das ist das
geschirr für der kantine
das ist die fußballmannschaft der schule
das ist die fußballmannschaft das ist
das training
das ist das training der
fußballmannschaft was ist das das ist
der eingang des fußballplatzes das ist
die flagge dänemarks die schönste flagge
der welt
[Musik]
[Applaus]